Before we discuss how to infer ancestral
states, I will pause to mention
that half a century ago, biologists
constructed trees from anatomical and
physiological properties
called "characters".
For example, here's a toy
character table for three species,
where the two characters considered are
whether the species have wings or not, and
how many legs the species have.
So, this brings us to the problem of
trying to reconstruct a phylogeny
from a character table.
Of course, I don't need Son
to swoop in and tell us that
this is currently not
a well defined problem.
In the modern era, constructing
a phylogeny from anatomical characters
seems crazy in some circumstances.
Just imagine trying to construct
a coronavirus phylogeny
from anatomical characters.
If you think for a moment about how we
would construct an evolutionary tree from
characters, then one idea you might
come up with would be to cluster
all organisms having the same character
on one side of the tree together.
For example, if we're considering
wings in stick insects,
we should probably put all winged stick
insects on one side of the tree, and
all of the wingless stick insects
on the other side of the tree.
This strategy is completely reasonable.
And, it's in keeping with
an over 100 year old postulate,
called "Dollo's principle
of irreversibility".
What this principle states is
that evolution is efficient:
it doesn't reinvent the same organ over
and over again such as insect wings.
Yet, when we construct the stick insect
phylogeny, we see that wings were gained
or lost at seven different times in stick
insects alone, shown here by stars.
When we then zoom out and
construct a phylogeny of all insects,
we see that wings have been gained or
lost hundreds of times.
This may seem like a mystery, but
what's going on is that evolution isn't
reinventing the wings from scratch.
The pathways needed for
flight aren't being eliminated
completely by eroding into pseudogenes.
They're just being used for
something else in wingless species;
then, they're getting turned back on
when they're needed in a winged species
to accommodate flight.
Accordingly, using genetic data
as characters has some merits.
We can bypass issues such as these.
In fact,
if we're given a multiple alignment,
then we can just view this alignment
as a character table of its own,
in which
each row corresponds to a species,
and each column of the multiple
alignment corresponds to
an individual character with up to
either four or 20 different values,
depending on whether we're looking at
a multiple alignment of DNA (or RNA),
or amino acids.
So, the question then, is how to
take this character table of sorts,
constructed from the multiple alignment,
in order to reconstruct ancestral states.